in the cuba issue um and see
status given to venezuelans while cubans
are being deported
the answer is yes yes
yes and by the way what you all know but
most people
don't know unlike the african-american
community with notable exceptions
the latino community is an incredibly
diverse community
with incredibly different attitudes
about different things
you go to florida you find a very
different attitude about immigration
in certain places than you do when
you're in arizona
so it's a very different a very diverse
community
there you go now this is this is i mean
this has become such a controversy he he
had to tweet a response now here's my
thing i don't know if i'm crazy
but of the things he said and the times
we've seen him kind of struggle to say
things
this to me seems like the least
controversial it depends
on how you interpret it if you're saying
like black people just are like
like you know so unsophisticated they
only believe one thing then that's bad
but if you're saying they mostly all
vote democrat
uh then he's saying the right thing
because i think what he was trying to
say
is that latin the latin community is
extremely diverse in the way they vote
and what they believe he should have
said that then though he should have
said that so it just came out wrong to
you
yeah if you i mean you forgot the main
thing if you say that
you know there's no diversity you know
in their voting that's one thing but if
you're just saying that all black people
are the same
yeah you might as well just put your
hood on baby i mean but
yeah to me what i heard is joe biden
said that
uh black people are inferior to whites
and that's just what i heard joe biden
just say
right so because yeah i i heard that too
but i think what he was probably trying
to say is that that black people
believe like they vote this way which is
also kind of a little bit of a
uh should be a wake up moment to blacks
being like yeah that
yeah we do kind of we're usually because
they're the only community that really
you know every other ethnic group kind
of there's people who vote both ways
almost equally absolutely here's what
needs to happen though is elon musk is
going to start to have to get
he's going to have to really speed it up
with those neural chips
they're going to have to get a neural
chip in biden's brain immediately
because
bubba's i mean he is so on the [ __ ]
ropes right now
i mean he may say in any interview he's
liable to say something
um wildly offensive about the black
community he said like three crazy
things about black people
already and then yes i was talking about
cocaine yeah but you know what
saying crazy [ __ ] got the [ __ ] orange
guy elected so
you never know it could just it could be
but you can't say anything about the
blacks you just cannot
no you cannot but okay so this is what
biden responded he tweeted back he had a
response
so this was his response on his twitter
because it was such a big controversy he
had to say
earlier today i made some comments and
then of course they forgot to put pause
for him [ __ ] his diapers so there's
a moment between i made some comments
where you have to pause he shits his
diaper
i made some comments about diversity in
the african-american and latino
communities that i want to clarify
in no way did i mean to suggest that the
african american community is a monolith
not by identity not on issues not at all
throughout my career i've witnessed the
diversity of thought blah blah
it's this diversity that makes her work
and then it's just [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] that i don't have to
so he's just bullshitting his way
instead of he should have said what i
meant to say
is that they mostly vote on the on my
side which is good
or he should have made a joke but he
tried to [ __ ] worm his way out of it
i've never stopped fighting for the
black so he just gave that
that uh you know uh you know that same
old kind of cliche apology joey b
all i'm saying to you jelly biting right
now is you better freaking
hope and pray that you don't get cut
into the turn to the left andrew schultz
video this weekend because if you do
you're over buddy you're gonna lose the
black vote
now there's one hope that he has and
people are starting to wonder because
she threw out a teaser
michelle obama released this statement
and it's like
wait a second [ __ ] what what
wait are you [ __ ] ready to work
work it girl you better work turn to the
left
[Music]
it's funny because when because of the
background it looks like you have no
arms sometimes
it just looks like you got no it looks
like you're a waitress
[Music]
because sometimes i just get inspired
and i gotta go fully charged work
cause you're a fat [ __ ]
guys because you're out of breath
yeah i had because i had two burgers and
two hot dogs for dinner and three bagels
it's what it is cuz yeah i have a
problem
you have a problem yeah you're
clinically saying we need to start
getting lithium into the burgers so you
just start to get better
work it michelle obama says she's
suffering from low grade depression v
what are we gonna do should we invite
her to the should we have her go rock
climbing with us this weekend in central
park
oh word yeah i'll bring the wine
mish what's going on girl so what she
said mish
mich said i know that i am dealing with
she goes i know that i'm dealing with
some form of low-grade depression
not just because of the quarantine but
because of the racial strife
and just seeing this administration
watching the hypocrisy of it
day in and day out is dispirited
it's dispiriting because i'm worrying
about something and there's a heaviness
does this mean that michelle the obama
shell shell
is gonna enter the race as the vp which
basically makes her the de facto
president
because the president's brain is dead
dead i mean cuz
if she comes in here's let me tell you
something let me be crystal [ __ ]
clear with you right now
if she comes in as the vice presidential
candidate biden might win every single
state
he might win every state i mean people
are [ __ ]
here for michelle obama she's [ __ ]
smart
she's a lawyer and she's the wife of
[ __ ] yas queen himself
obama obama and she's jacked
make no mistake michelle obama she might
be able to beat the [ __ ] out of any
president in the world
because she's in shape beautiful woman
she's hot she's i think she's probably
the hottest
first lady since since um since jackie i
mean those are two
yas queens who were [ __ ] young and
hot and she is a hottie
pattati yas but she's also eloquent
because
she's one of the most eloquent first
ladies harvard grad lawyer um
you know what i don't care what your
politics are i just missed the days
where
i looked at the president and i said
that guy would never have a beer with me
and that's a good thing okay and that
yeah and that's a good good thing
so you know what can you do yeah what
can you do when your president's getting
interviewed by
the head of barstool you're in a [ __ ]
it's a problem
yeah i just want to get back to where
they're just where we're the bad guys
and they're
and they're they're the [ __ ] powerful
ones i don't wanna
i don't wanna feel like i'm i could sit
down with the president and i could
really
nail some opinions for him and here we
go as the headlines roll out this
morning we start to see some truths and
some members of our staff have been
lying to us
hundreds of new homeless turned upper
west side into a spectacle of drugs and
harassment
so yeah but that was just v and her
perea that's what okay but i also want
to know
v are you really just looking for
parking are you living in your car
because you're homeless
[Music]